[Music]
let's check with cody and boise hi cody
how are you
good how are you guys doing better than
we deserve what's up
good um i just so i want to preface this
first by like i feel like i'm almost
going behind my watch back and calling
to talk about this
um so here we go like me and my wife
we've kind of been starting our
debt-free journey here the last i want
to say a year so been a little bit
davish we get really good and then kind
of fall back but we fall back together
my wife wants to be a motivational
speaker so she's been really
trying to get on that gun
and i want to support her with
everything i can
um she came to me a couple days ago
saying that she had a phone call with
some people from the speaker lab
um said it was a free call
just to kind of see where she's going
see what they could do to help
her after the call she gave me a call
and said don't be mad
i just spent five thousand dollars
why wouldn't you be mad
of course you're going to be because
yeah of course you're gonna be mad
you guys were in agreement on what you
were doing and then she just got on
there and got sold
of course you're gonna be mad why
wouldn't you be mad
well
we we don't ever spend even 20 30
without talking to each other yeah so i
mean she just bought a freaking car man
yes
so how did she pay for this
so like i said we've been davis we've
been paying a credit card off we had the
credit card down cancel the sale just
call them and tell them you're not doing
it
she did it in increments she put well i
wouldn't say she paid eight or five
thousand dollars she did nine hundred
dollars yesterday and it just kept
happening just tell them you're not
doing it i know those guys tell them
tell them we said to refund them do you
really yeah they're local guys
really
i just looked it up i thought i
recognized that name
and so uh yeah i i think if they're
reasonable people you say hey listen
we're on the ramsey plan we're trying to
get a debt we didn't talk about this we
really can't afford this right now
and see what they say there's no
promises you know their business but
i think they might be willing to work
with you on this
i don't think they have a choice to be
honest with you i think you can just
cancel the sale or you say i'll talk to
the credit card company we'll have it
you know
refunded that way but
yeah this is i mean this bigger than
this this is financial infidelity and we
got to get on the same page and there's
no more dave ish if we're going to do
this thing you're not going to get any
progress if you take one step forward
three steps back
so we have to really go what's at the
root that's causing us to fall back time
and time again do we really want this
what is our why do we have a strong
enough why what is our vision for the
family why are we trying to get out of
debt
uh but this is a reset you guys need to
have
as a couple
okay
i get she has dreams and she wants to be
a motivational speaker but right now
we've got to focus on getting out of
debt so that we can make a lot of money
speaking i've never paid him by five
thousand dollars to get to learn how to
do it
yeah because
when she talked to me she was really
excited about it and then they gave her
these promises of what will give you
this many leads we'll help you build
your website we'll do this do that
and a free call just turned into a lot
of money well they're great sales people
apparently yeah it's okay if
the their service is valid you're not in
a position to buy their service today
you're too broke
okay and she's not in a position to
spend five thousand dollars to start a
small business today
you're broke right
and so we can you know
so what she needs to do is continue to
work on her craft continue to grow
continue to get reps listen there's only
one thing at the end of the day that
causes people to be world-class speakers
uh and that is just well two things
studying your craft ongoing
and reps
lots of reps
step up on the stage and talk step up on
the stage and talk step up on the stage
and talk and it's not a class and it's
not a website and it's not leads it's
reps
so a class a website leads all that'll
work but um
you know cody i would this sale needs to
be canceled uh for lots of reasons one
is you can't afford it two is she
violated ural's trust and she should be
ashamed about that
instead of like don't be mad
you know yes i'm mad you know you're
dead i'm right i'm mad
you know you 5 000 for my listen man i'm
a multi-millionaire my wife doesn't
spend five thousand dollars i don't
spend five thousand talking to her on
something like this now we obviously
have transactions at the business here
that sharon's not involved in on a daily
basis and she's happy for it but in
terms of yeah she doesn't want to screw
with it but but in terms of things that
sharon and i are doing in our personal
life i don't book trips with a personal
hey i booked a trip for us to go on
vacation i would go over like a dadgum
lead balloon yeah whether you're a
millionaire or not this is a huge
financial advice you just you just make
major decisions together and you don't
throw a grenade over the fence and go
don't be mad i'm sorry i'm mad yeah you
did come right i'm mad
you know it just doesn't work that way
it doesn't work that way so no i and
then george is right the biggest issue
at the core of this whole thing is the
two of you've gotta decide what you're
gonna be
you know this you've been screwing
around with the edges of this thing are
you really going to get real and do it
or not
and get yourself out of debt and we're
not trying to sell you anything
we just we just want to sell you on
changing your life
transforming your life that's one of the
beauties of cutting up the credit card
and being broke is you don't have a
choice you can't go spend five thousand
dollars if you wanted to
hey
there's an idea
one you know if there's a debit card and
there's not five thousand dollars in the
checking account you don't accidentally
spend it
and go don't be mad you don't have that
as an option
and that's why it's fun to spend your
own money because you make decisions
differently there it is yeah there's one
angle
but i'll reach out to them myself if i
have to to remedy the situation for cody
oh that's not cool wow george has got
pull i've got so much pull around here
dave you have no idea he knows people
so uh also make sure you get cody's uh
number to cancel the sale which is what
me if phone
they should do uh big george is going to
step in for him okay thank you for
calling me big dave that's the first and
the last it's gonna happen it's gonna
happen